vamos a realizar este ejercicio y nos
dice el carbono 14 es un elemento que
pierde exactamente la mitad de su masa
cada cinco mil setecientos treinta años
la masa de una muestra de carbono 14
puede moderarse con una función m que
depende de su edad
y está dada
muy bien dice medimos que la masa
inicial de una muestra de carbono 14 es
de 741 gramos escribe una función que
modele la masa de la muestra de carbono
14 restante después de t años
transcurridos desde la medición inicial
muy bien entonces como siempre te invito
a que hagas una pausa trates de resolver
este problema por tu propia cuenta trata
de dar tú mismo una función m que
dependa de ti y que nos mida la masa de
la muestra de carbono 14 restante como
función de los años transcurridos
muy bien a mí la forma en que me gusta
digamos abordar este tipo de problemas
es primero tratar de hacer una tablita
así que vamos a hacer una tablita en
donde podamos poner el número de años
transcurridos y también que nos diga
cuál es la masa restante de nuestra
muestra ok entonces digamos que estamos
al tiempo cero es decir estamos con la
medición inicial verdad y nuestra
medición inicial nos dice que digamos
déjenme
déjenme subrayar lo es la masa inicial
de una muestra de carbono 14 es de 741
gramos entonces al tiempo cero es decir
al momento inicial tenemos 741 gramos
muy bien ahora la otra digamos la otra
información valiosa que tenemos es que
la masa aquí lo tenemos verdad pierde
exactamente la mitad de su masa cada
cinco mil setecientos treinta años
entonces digamos si pasaran cinco mil
setecientos treinta años cuánta masa
tendríamos pues tendríamos 741 y lo
multiplicamos por un medio verdad eso es
lo mismo que dividirlo a la mitad muy
bien qué pasaría si ahora tenemos dos
veces cinco mil setecientos treinta años
es decir ocurren cinco mil setecientos
treinta años después de estos que ya
habían ocurrido entonces tendremos la
mitad de este número que será 741 por un
medio
y para obtener la mitad de esto hay que
multiplicar por un medio verdad y esto
lo podríamos simplemente escribir como
741 por un medio elevado al cuadrado
entonces si te das cuenta entre cada
paso lo digamos del tiempo cero al 5700
30 hay que multiplicar por un medio del
este paso al siguiente es decir cuando
ocurren otros 5.700 30 años hay que
multiplicar por un medio si quisiéramos
saber cuánta masa hay una vez que
ocurren cinco mil setecientos treinta
años nuevamente verdad es decir ya
ocurrieron tres veces 5.730 entonces
nuevamente tendríamos que multiplicar
por un medio y que eso sería 741 por un
medio elevado
verdad entonces puedes notar un patrón
aquí cada cinco mil setecientos treinta
años elevamos un medio al exponente
correspondiente al número de vidas
medias de esta sustancia que han pasado
verdad aquí la vida media de las
sustancias son cinco mil setenta
perdón cinco mil setecientos treinta
años entonces cada vez que ocurre una
hay que elevar al exponente
correspondiente verdad y después hay que
multiplicar por 741 entonces esto ya nos
da la información necesaria para poder
plantear la función que estamos buscando
la masa como función del número de años
que han ocurrido será un medio bueno
vamos a poner mejor primero 741 por un
medio elevado al número de años que
perdona el número de vidas medias que
han ocurrido como sabemos la cantidad de
vidas medias que han ocurrido
tenemos que dividir el número de años
que han pasado entre cinco mil
setecientos treinta así que por ejemplo
cuando el número de años es cinco mil
setecientos treinta entonces tendremos
que ha ocurrido una vida media cuando
tenemos dos veces cinco mil 732 veces
cinco mil 730 entre cinco mil
setecientos treinta nos da dos verdad
que es el número de vidas medias que han
ocurrido y así puedes darte cuenta que
esta es la forma en que podemos extender
a cualquier número de años incluso si
son si son por ejemplo fracciones de
vida media verdad entonces aquí quedará
un exponente fraccionario así que esta
de aquí es nuestra función que puede
modelar la masa de nuestra muestra de
carbono 14 verdad como función del
número de años que van transcurriendo